say subscribe to subscribe no no like
hold on let me see it hey guys so before
you subscribe uh we want to give you a
warning that there are some bad words in
this episode that were said somewhat
frequently and we've done our best to uh
limit those words but there's a few that
have slipped so anyway i just a warning
if you're sensitive to that stuff uh
still subscribe and enjoy hello welcome
back to the iced coffee hour i'm michael
reeves and to date this podcast the iced
coffee hour has made over seven hundred
dollars
yeah that's right that's correct and a
fantastic guess yeah 186 thousand two
hundred and seventy dollars and 81 cents
wow that's really good yeah
so
yeah it is
well we're very excited to have you come
all the way to las vegas to come visit
with us
film a little segment for your video and
it's been has it been over a year not
over really but it's approaching
yeah in there approaching a year so
touching it a year ago we met for the
first time we filmed a video together
where i went through your finances yeah
yeah you shared almost over a year over
a year ago yeah yeah you shared how much
money you made and what you were
spending it on you really didn't spend a
lot of money no but you invested a lot
in simon property group i did do that
yeah yeah but recently you you gave me a
whammy here that uh you sold everything
i sold everything yeah yeah michael saw
that running when did you
we'll get to that we gotta we gotta hook
the viewer okay uh
by the way you subscribe because we we
look through
and apparently we've been not asking to
subscribe enough so our conversions are
down so how about this if you're
watching right now and you haven't
already subscribed just do us that quick
favor just hit the button that's it it's
easy super easy to do so thank you so
much and uh michael for those who don't
know you um you make like you post once
a year but your one video a year is like
the best video of the year like they're
all these just like
incredible concepts that you'll spend
like 10 months making with robotics
uh just weird stuff uh and tasers
or or sometimes urine you'll incorporate
into the videos yeah you're inspired
part of mine so yeah if someone asks
what you do
how do you describe that i lie usually
okay i usually lie like if it's someone
who doesn't know what i do i'll lie and
i say i'm in do i do computers and i'll
just [ __ ] leave it at that because
it's like how i don't know how to
explain what i actually do
like yeah i like youtube make robot
go fast yeah but you come up with these
ideas like uh yours was trying to get
one of those eighty thousand dollar
robots
to pee beer
yeah into a cup yeah
and to aim it and to like pee into the
cup but then what was surprising to me
is that on top of all of that you
actually made a road trip
to the headquarters to have the dog pee
on the headquarters yeah how do you come
up with those ideas and like
where does that all start illness okay
the frontal lobe
chemical imbalance yeah
um
yeah that one was [ __ ] that one i was
just like this video is not able to end
in a funny way i wanted to just drive
also i was watching a lot of um you guys
ever watched all gas no brakes for me
yeah of course yeah i love yeah i just
watched a vice video where they did an
interview with him and he was like
talking about his like life on the road
now he's like [ __ ] all over the
united states and i was like that sounds
sick that sounds
flipping epic and so i was like i want
to drive across the united states
someday and it just happened to line up
really well i was like i remember it was
like really late in the night it was
like 4am or something and i was like
doing
that video i was like
[ __ ] how do i end it and i like
scribbled in my notebook i just wrote
boston question mark and it was like
[ __ ] i i know i gotta go to boston to do
that yeah also they like wouldn't sell
me the dog originally so i was mad at
them and that's why i had to piss on
there what do you mean they wouldn't say
well they they didn't offer it um like
they wouldn't offer it to the public it
was only for like testing in industrial
sectors and stuff at first so they just
like literally wouldn't sell it to me
which sucked i was going to make like a
fake company and purchase it through
that but
they ended up finally selling it to the
public but i was still yeah they know
who you are i mean don't you have a
person i don't think that's what they're
going for and wouldn't that like be
incredible marketing for them as well
that's what they're going for i don't
think that's what they're going for i
think they're going for it lives in an
amazon warehouse and never sees the sun
that's a customer demo
for sure yeah yeah i don't think they
wanted to be they did i think they made
a reference to the pissing they made it
piss tequila or something
they did some kind of quirky reference
which was nice yeah i actually met a guy
who
it's always fun to see like when i make
a video and it talks heavily about like
a company how like that company reacts i
talked to randomly talk to like the
nephew of someone who works at davinci
robotics i made a video about like
surgery yeah surgery robot they
apparently like that one they like that
i think boston dynamics liked it a lot
less
because i was more
spiteful towards them surely yeah yeah
you know the reason the parking lot was
empty was because i didn't plan it at
all but i got there like on
a holiday like black friday or something
and the whole [ __ ] park yeah the
whole parking lot was empty barren not a
single soul there yeah it was really i
know you and the gates were open yeah
dudes drove in
and there was a security guard around
but we had a [ __ ] boston dynamics
robot dog at boston dynamics they would
have cooked anyone else out but we had
the dog and they're like they obviously
work here
clearly that do you think that person
got in trouble
just like left he looked at us he was
like staring at us from like a hill and
they're like but he saw the dog and so
he went away
wow okay
but i have to say you know your your
rise on youtube coming from like a
college dorm room i remember the video
you did where you did like what was it
with an energy drink right you had the
energy drink like try to spray it at you
or like when i was in college i did a
laser eye thing
i did it poked me in the eye with a
laser right so it was basically a laser
pointer that would find your eye and
then direct
yeah that was sick how do you learn all
this stuff like well that one was like
yeah i'm like trying to learn
like facial detection
and then it was like
i also know how to make motors go and so
it'd be like it was like interesting to
make like a target what it's detecting
and it was like it a really common thing
that things detect is like your face or
your eye so it's like that's
[ __ ] epic that one was like a side
project because that was like the first
video i ever made yeah so it was like a
side project to like get away from
working my job and going to college
so that one was just for i mean they're
all for funsies but that one was like a
side project just a meme i also turned
it in as an english report
and i got a good grade
huh you turned into that exact video i
didn't know the robot as it oh the
english project
how does that work
what's the relationship correlation i
don't even i stretched it so hard i
remember bringing in a class and
everyone was like ooh robot and that was
like probably the selling point yeah but
yeah i was in english and it was like do
a project about this i it was something
about like how
i don't know
something about finding a goal and
tracking it i was like i made this track
your eye and the english professor was
like yes all right it sounds like you
made them separately but you fell behind
on the other one you're like how can i
merge this that is exactly i tried to
turn it in for every class
whoever takes it yeah whoever
people's eyes too yeah
oh man but how do you find an interest
in that like where did this all start to
because because like i would see that
and be like that's that's cool but i
couldn't i couldn't figure out how to do
it like i wouldn't have enough interest
to like see i like um i started
programming like as a way to not be
homeless or any or die so i was
graduating in high school bad grades
wasn't good at much so
just like program i'll just pick
something it was between like
i remember like i was i was like i'll
choose between uh programming video
editing and psychology because i liked
all three yeah as interests um
just want programming because it's
easier to learn online
so yeah i've been doing that
ever since how'd you learn online do you
guys go to websites yeah no no not
program i i like youtube videos i have a
hard time like learning through books
and learning in class because i really
like to rewind i don't learn super fast
so like i need to watch it like three
times over
so like you know just you have my finger
on the backspace button and write it
down yeah so so did you actually learn
programming to not be homeless or was
that like well like to
to like to have a job after high school
yeah yeah yeah to have a job after high
school and be able to do something yeah
because i i really wasn't like i was
failing most classes i was not good at
much things like i think the only class
i got above being was like a stat was in
stats
what were you doing then at that age
other than school uh video games being
epic
swagging
um
minecraft
lots of minecraft lots of smash brothers
okay um
yeah just living life sometimes i just
wouldn't go to class it would be fun it
would be a dude my high school was sweet
i i would just sometimes
um when my parents wouldn't have work i
i was able to drive to school
and so if i had the car i would just go
to um the convenience store and get a
spam with a b and i just drive right
past the school and i'd like go up into
the uh the mountain it's a haleakala on
maui i go to the mountain and i just
[ __ ] sit and like look at the whole
island and just eat my spammers would be
until like 10 a.m and then i'd get to
school and i just show up
and they'd be like hey hello
and and like yeah so what's the how do
you not get in trouble for doing that i
think you we did eventually my class in
high school was the shittiest class for
i think in the the 25 years the school
has been
in existence because there was never any
late policy but my class was so late
they made it so if you're late you get a
detention
and i ended the school year with over a
hundred detentions
isn't it better just to
get the school out of the way earlier is
the detention same time is like the
school that you're saying well the thing
is because i i didn't do serve 100
attentions i could do like stuff for
teachers and they would they would take
it off in bulk
like you know they'd be like i don't
know i changed the guy's ram and his
computer and he was like i'll take 10
off
that sounds like bribery what's the
difference better
than a hundred and yeah
i was in band and so i had a
they had the library where they store
all the music i had like a sleeping bag
behind some boxes and i would just go
back there and sleep for the school day
it was lit it was so cool no one gave a
[ __ ] my senior year but first i want to
thank our sponsor ftx investing in
crypto can be very daunting but with ftx
it doesn't have to be ftx is a crypto
exchange that unlike other exchanges has
no fees whatsoever when you buy or sell
crypto they're trusted by over 6 million
people to buy sell and keep track of all
of their favorite cryptocurrencies with
ftx you can set up recurring buys
allowing you to invest money directly
from your bank account automatically
every single month with ftx every trade
you make over ten dollars you can earn
free crypto so instead of paying fees to
invest you could be getting paid and the
ftx app can give you important news
updates and news feeds directly from top
crypto projects and they even offer a
crypto friendly debit card which allows
you to spend crypto at millions of
merchants worldwide you can use the ftx
app to buy your favorite nfts with no
gas fees supporting both ethereum and
solana blockchains so start trading
crypto and nfts with no fees today with
the link down below in the description
on the ftx app again guys use the link
down below in the description to start
trading today with absolutely no fees
thank you so much ftx and back to the
podcast yeah seniors could get away with
a lot more because they're kind of over
you and they kind of know that you're
going to be gone pretty soon and like
you know especially last six months they
really just like slide yeah they're like
yeah they're
yeah i bet you didn't know this but for
me in my senior year i made a fake
doctor's letterhead so i printed it off
of google
and i found like a real like info but i
said that i had a condition of sleep
apnea that prevented me from getting a
full night of sleep nice and that that
was the reason why i'd have to get to
school at 10 a.m
so i would i actually turned this in and
they they never questioned it they never
called and they took it at face value
and so for most of my senior year i
would get to school at 10 or it was like
10 30 because they had a 10 like a 30
minute like break or whatever so 10 30.
but then i also wanted to miss one day
of school a week so on top of that i'd
only go into school four days a week and
i did that my entire senior year but i
would go and work did they didn't think
anything of it um
i don't think they knew
i don't think they really knew uh my i s
because i would go in late but i think i
lied to my mom i just said that like my
school starts at 10.
my mom's like yeah
checks out
my dad knew but he didn't do anything
about it i think it's more just like you
know you're going to do what you want to
do you should shouldn't do that but
yeah he was pretty good about but i
wasn't like a bad i was a bad student
but i did i didn't get into you didn't
defy authority i didn't get in trouble
yeah so like when i was skipping school
i'd go and like open up
work
yeah open up the warehouse yeah usually
i would um be ignoring school would be
to like be learning programming
um yeah and my parents were like mad at
me for doing that and we had like a
counselor's meeting and they'd be like
you gotta stop doing this
this is you gotta learn english and i
was like no this is better
yeah so i would ignore other stuff to
learn what i was doing but you learned
it on youtube like youtube youtube yeah
youtube okay youtube's like the best but
some dude you can go on there and
there's like a hundred part series of
just this random guy in india doing a
full course on java or c sharp or python
and it's all good quality stuff like the
same stuff you learn in college some
stuff you're learning but how do you
expect to graduate high school that's
the same and say like i've learned
everything on youtube is do they not
check that like you went through like a
program or anything or is it just like i
learned on youtube like if you're doing
an engineering job yeah um well like
they they do care a lot less now because
they know that you can just learn it
from a computer i mean it's like
computer stuff it kind of makes sense
you can learn it on a computer like you
wouldn't want your doctor to be a
youtube taught doctor but
right you want to go to medical school
but yeah like this is a senior surgery
robot video
there's like a lot of people at like
spacex and tesla especially like those
are some of the
like more progressive companies like the
fan companies don't give a [ __ ] if
you've been to
college for
programming they just want to know what
you can do and like see your portfolio
that's part of why they have like such
um interview processes like you have to
know how to do a bunch of [ __ ] on a
whiteboard and that's annoying but like
it doesn't matter how you know how to do
it you just know how to do it that's
interesting so did you actually end up
getting a job and
in that after high school yeah yeah i
worked for the the government of hawaii
for a bit
little bits at the college um on my
island got it yeah i know when you're
working for the government i would
imagine
there's got to be some like mischievous
stuff you were doing on the side or were
you just like dude going in like were
you not changing just on the back end
and like not a lot i didn't have a lot
of action
we had our own server okay so if we
didn't have access to any other
place um unfortunately i feel like you
would send out like mass emails or just
like you know there's memes or like
something something you would do
something in there okay but you kept it
pretty pretty you know i kept it pretty
professional okay you did kept it good
yeah okay and like i was i was such like
a serious nerd in that job too i was
like trying to do it really well um
yeah i remember like getting mad at the
other
people there who were like uh who were
going to college for it but working on
the project as well
so it was yeah that was an interesting
time and then
i started working remote as i started
going to college um
and i started hating it so i started
learning other stuff on the side and
that's why i made that laser eye robot
and did that video initially just take
off or did it take a few videos i don't
know i think it was just read it like
the first one
so that was nice yeah it was fun i
remember going to work and being like oh
my god it has a hundred views this is
[ __ ] crazy
yeah i was flipping out because i posted
it on reddit as well yeah on our slash
robots which is a great subreddit yeah
yeah but why do you quit your job i know
you hated it but wasn't it like good
money i didn't quit for a while yeah um
i still do random stuff tried to do
random stuff on the side
um
it wasn't that good of money because
it's like the government of hawaii yeah
and maui especially is like does not
invest in their i.t infrastructure a lot
so
yeah they were asking a lot and also
they scammed the [ __ ] out of me my boss
definitely like underpaid me because i
didn't have the degree but i was doing
more than the people who did have the
degree that's crazy yeah how did you
find out about that um someone told me
yeah yeah i was like that's not right
also at some point i worked like
that was my first 100 hour work week was
on that project and she and they did not
pay like
they couldn't pay over a certain amount
of overtime so it would just bleed into
the next month or next week and not
count as overtime it's like can you say
how much you were making at that job i
actually don't remember oh oh wait yeah
it was fifteen dollars an hour twelve
dollars an hour wow um and with with
time and a half for overtime which was
good out of high school because i i
didn't have any scholarships
so i worked i had to work like
i had to max out overtime to pay for
college that summer
and going into college too because i
didn't have scholarships because my
grades were bad yeah yeah so
yeah and then you went to college and
then you dropped out of college yeah
yeah and when you dropped out were you
continuing to do this work remotely yeah
i was still doing remote after doing
youtube and then all this you know after
some time youtube income started taking
over that job jeez jack we could just
ask you
i'm just i'm just curious because i
think i know that i think i know that
you know the problem
you know the high school the youtube
pipeline yeah you know that yeah why do
you why did you uh drop out of college i
[ __ ] college sucks
[Laughter]
that college specific well also i went
to college to follow my girlfriend at
the time which was a bad idea
um i went to northern arizona university
which is a
[ __ ] that college
um
well it's it's definitely one of those i
think all colleges are pretty money sync
but that one's a real money sink it's
like the reason i got in was because
they have a 93 acceptance rate they just
want your money they don't give a like
they don't care about anything else um
the computer science program was
okay if you could get higher up in it
but they wouldn't even let me like
um test out of the intro class and i
didn't mean to be like an [ __ ] like
you should let me
skip a whole class i was like can you
let me take the finals and all the tests
uh because i was already working as a
programmer
so i was like why am i working as a
programmer to pay to go to school to
learn how to work as a programmer that's
stupid that doesn't make any sense yeah
um
yeah so that sucked and uh
after that year my girlfriend moved to
oahu so i moved with her
and i was going to continue school there
and i remember like looking at the
registration like i'm not going to do
that so i just lived in oahu for a year
which was bad that was a bad time and
then what happened to that relationship
gone dead dying and deceased what
happened it's just oh it just fizzled
out yeah it was just a relationship it
should have ended like two years prior
okay yeah we were we did in high school
yeah and so yeah yeah
yeah
she is not a bad person but okay no yeah
it wasn't anything like horrendous it
was just like you didn't yeah you should
just know when you should
move on to different shows yeah
she's not a bad person got it but when
you posted this youtube video was that a
sign for you just like you got to post
more youtube videos no
really no yeah no i was just continuing
with my life but that was a cool thing
yeah
yeah it was just a cool thing so what
happened after that so so now you're in
oahu yeah broke you broke up you were
not going to college no we're still
together in oahu oh you are yeah yeah
but you broke up there no no still
together oh you're still yeah
i want to know we're still together
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i'm just trying to get the timelines
no yeah i was in oahu for a year
together for the whole thing but it just
didn't work out just imagine did you
move to new york
just ask jack he knows the timeline
jack when did they freak out
things just weren't working out they
should have broke up two years prior
you know they were high school humans
different yeah
but first i want to thank our sponsor
huel alex i am starving but i have no
idea what to eat i wish there was just
an easy to make meal supplement with all
of the proteins carbs fats fibers and 27
other essential vitamins and minerals i
need on a day-to-day basis there is jack
it's called huel and it's exactly what
it sounds like human fuel fuel for
humans without proper nutrition i have
less energy my overall mood is worse and
also i get significantly less work done
that's why i think of huel as an
investment not only can it save me time
for work it makes the time i do spend
working actually matter just mix their
plant-based powder with water and you
will feel fantastic and more efficient
for the rest of your day they even have
a heel black edition which has less
carbs and even more protein there's
nothing like ending a workout with some
heel black edition huel also has hot and
savory meals which include mac and
cheese thai green chili and a few others
that you have to try and they take less
than five minutes to make fuel is proof
that fast food can be good food i love
it and you'll love it too and right now
you can get free shipping on your first
order plus a shaker and a free t-shirt
so go to huel.com ich that's hewl.com
h-u-e-l-dot-com slash ich for free
shipping a free shaker and a free
t-shirt thank you so much fuel and back
to the podcast i have to ask you too
because i was in band too yeah and
there's a connotation to uh to every
instrument
yeah whatever right let me guess let me
guess okay yeah you're uh
were you a sax man yesterday
yeah my next guess uh my next guest is
going to be don't hate me but my next
test is going to be trumpet that's
not that's not that bad that's not
offensive yeah
dude yeah the saxophones were it was
such a um being in band they uh the
saxophones were like we were wild
wild yeah we're just attacking one two
yeah me too yeah when did you play
uh i played the alto and then i switched
to tenner oh i did both as well yeah
nice yeah um
the our band director was a saxophonist
so the saxophone could just do anything
it was awesome my section leader one
time just stood up and said hey mister
[ __ ] you and sat back down in the middle
of band and the band master is like haha
that's funny
he went back to doing this
they were like friends it wasn't in like
a mean way but it was like
it was all over the place gosh guess
what i played
wait you played
yeah i did repercussion i'm not gonna
just just give a guess uh i played an
instrument in band trumpet
perk percussion perks pushing t i would
say the same
the tuba
sits on the side of the chair and the
thing would like go off yeah
yeah
but i didn't realize how much wind it
takes like you do get like really
blended yeah yeah a lot of gross spit
too you have to dump out of that
yeah dude bedrooms are not sanitary
places like
100 kids just dump it on the ground yeah
they'll just what would they call the
little pipe at the end
at the water pit valve yeah
yeah you just like the brass players
would open it up and go yeah it's gross
yeah saxophones never did you just
dumped it out oh yeah it was really
yucky never would sit on a bathroom
floor ever that's disgusting yeah in
middle school ours was carpeted too
which made it yeah it's all carpeted
yeah
high school was linoleum so luckily got
it yeah okay yeah what's wrong with you
jack
yeah so the story continues right so you
ended up you know you and your
girlfriend you separated yeah you were
still living on the island nope
see i told you guys so you guys are
trying to figure this out the whole time
on the wall we were together
okay so you moved out of oahu right yeah
yeah yeah
i moved to california and then broke up
okay we're in california i moved in with
william osman oh he was like a youtuber
who does text stuff as well um i was in
oxnard that was an awesome yeah because
his [ __ ] house burned down wow which
i made so much fun of him before it was
awesome funny thing it was funny yeah he
showed me his burn down house
i had some good jabs in there that i did
not get on video unfortunately yeah
that's were you doing youtube at that
time yeah yeah yeah yeah
so that's why i um that's how he knew me
i came over for like two weeks to work
on a project for this other guy like
unrelated to youtube just programming
pure um
but during that time i was able like go
up to see will and we like did a video
and it was fun and his house were down
so we
we then
got a place to go got a place yeah yeah
okay yeah it's fun at what point did you
realize that youtube was actually like
uh gonna be financially supportive of
you it never really feels that way or
ever felt that way it was just like it
makes sense i don't really remember a
time
yeah i don't really remember a time it
just happened and i just
would quit i quit one job at some point
and just did not find another one what
was the job you quit
that was working remote for uh
well uh the university got it yeah how
much were you making there still
more than 15 like maybe 20 okay an hour
um
which is like not a bad amount of money
but for i think the programming work the
people it was maddening because the
people in the same roles were getting
paid a lot more
yeah so yeah i would assume you'd you
would have been making a lot more do you
really feel like it was not having that
degree that held you back well i think
that's what they would say is an excuse
to not pay you more
um
yeah because i i was
like i was like
um
like spearheading implementations and
stuff and like asking the other people
like
like the other it was like two separate
teams i was like talking to the other
team i was putting together like
uh like workflow diagrams of like how
the database fit together i was doing
like a lot of the [ __ ] like and so
it was like mainly the one working on it
so it felt like that they were just
using that as an excuse to not pay you
did you negotiate maybe you just gotta
push harder and negotiate these jobs oh
i did actually she did for a raise yeah
and they were like that's how i learned
you need a degree and i was like
but why not go in there
with a higher number to begin with
um
i was 19 years old maybe that's part of
it um
yeah yeah definitely now know how we
know how to ask for a raise yeah
yeah
yeah i almost ended up working for or
doing work for raytheon oh yeah the
missile company cool but i did not want
to go to tucson
and they were like
that was the best i was offering so
believe it or not i met up with a
subscriber
uh who took me and macy had for sushi he
works there oh yeah he's getting paid
pretty well i mean i think it was he was
right out of college
making like almost six figures yeah
working there and he's like if i stay
there like they they pay really well
they have locations
in multiple parts yeah seems like a good
gig and it seems like that is a stepping
stone too is like yeah it's really good
it's a good game yeah yeah but tucson
i want to
yeah from maui to there so so now you're
doing youtube yeah how much were you
making in the beginning on youtube
uh i don't know
i enough i don't look 20 years
enough to live i that's really the only
time i look at the money is like i have
enough to live
i'm very non like financial
oriented i mean i pick my own stocks and
all that yeah but i don't usually look
at like my monthly or like yearly
stuff like that yeah
i i don't really remember i remember
being really excited when i owned over
like five thousand dollars in my bank
account yeah i was like this has never
happened before this is the coolest
thing is that from youtube or was that
from there it was from both it was from
just everything working together yeah
got it yeah i was real frugal on on oahu
i ate only ham sandwiches okay with only
ham and white bread yeah to the point
where i got like a stomach problem oh
wow like it was called gerd grass
gastric esophageal reflux disease every
time i would eat grease i'd get
heartburn for like three hours
my brother i think has sucks yeah yeah
it's not good yeah so then i yeah so i
had to take some medication for that
what causes that is that something
that's like a like a genetic something
or anything just diet i think maybe you
could cause that to yourself there's a
lot of grease already right i thought it
was like a lot of if you eat a lot of
grease it i don't know like maybe it was
i just remember eating like chili and
then every time i would have grease it
would like get really bad yeah something
like that yeah but it got fixed yeah got
it yeah and now you're in kind of an
interesting situation because
you you started twitch streaming a
little bit you haven't streamed on
twitch in a while yeah right was that
like a half a year or something yeah
wait a second so i thought uh after we
met weren't you the the number one most
subscribed to person in like a month on
twitch there's something where it was
like some r you broke a record in terms
of like subscribers in one month or like
i don't know yeah you're talking to
pokemon you might have been talking to
boca yourself no it was you yeah i think
it was the first month that you joined
yeah you gained the most subscribers of
anybody or what is it followers and
subscribers subscribers on twitch in a
month like the first month um
yeah
yeah right so if i were doing it for
money i would just do that but sometimes
streaming is a weird thing like i prefer
youtube to it just because like you
never get a moment when you're like
i i did i did it you know you know on
youtube you like make a thing and you
edit it and you like throw it out and
you're like good
on twitch it's just like a constant lull
unless you're doing like huge projects
yeah um
so it's just like a constant lull the
only time i really love twitch um and i
do still like
want to do it but it just hasn't
like felt like a
like a good time to is when i'm really
like obsessed with something so like
when i think they did like a modded
minecraft server and i was streaming
like 12 hours a day i was going at it so
much it was really fun because i was
just like super into minecraft at the
time
there's a mod where you can code in
minecraft
[ __ ] awesome
i made like an automated melon farm
because the server had less food as like
a
fun thing okay so i made like a vending
machine out of melons wow that was
really cool yeah graham has never
touched minecraft
see how much do you make from that
that's what i want to know the numbers
from twitch yeah like if you're
streaming 12 hours a day
how many people are watching it's gonna
be like 10 20 000 surely more i think
more than if you like put the amount i
did youtube and the amount i did twitch
probably twitch would make more
i think
yeah probably twitch would make more but
also yeah but then if i'm like bummed
out because i'm like not having if i'm
not into it then it's like why no one
wants to watch that right but like let's
say in an average day on twitch if you
stream all day yeah how much would you
make from something like that i don't
know it's been a while since i've
streamed on twitch like
i'm not have you seen that leak um yeah
i did yeah um but i guess that's the top
of the top people um i don't i don't
remember ever checking like at the end
of the day
so a few grand a few grand
probably okay something like that yeah
see it's so odd to me because i'd be
checking that like every minute dude
that's like brain poison no it's not
numbers like mental acid why do you not
care about finances
because then
i don't know because then i'm okay it
makes sense for you guys you have a
financial youtube channel it makes sense
for a lot of people it makes sense for a
lot of people but like i think if i were
just focused on that then i would end up
making
content that i weren't super hyped about
yeah um yeah and i want it to be
not just a job
for as long as it can be
yeah so yeah i want to enjoy every bit
of it that's
maybe that's like
make less money but higher in enjoyment
right so i'm just curious because it
seems like uh
you'll basically do an offer you'll post
a video or something yeah like a year's
worth of expenses covered
do what you want for a year
and then when it comes time to be like
you know i need the next year then be
like what am i what am i excited about
let me let me do this
or it just kind of comes up naturally
usually in a year you'll find something
where you get excited about it that'll
kind of yeah push for the next year i'm
trying to like learn stuff randomly and
like get when i'm excited about new
technology and [ __ ] okay yeah but it's
not like i'm running out of money i
should make a youtube video
it's like um if i'm like this is a cool
idea i should make a youtube video kind
of but let's say that doesn't happen
let's say it's five years goes down the
line oh and i just don't you're just
like i'm not i'm not not interested i'm
gonna have to find a job doing something
else
i probably will find a job doing
something else if i if i just lost
interest in it okay but i haven't yet
which is why i'm trying to keep
interested right yeah so it's
interesting that you haven't lost
interest in youtube but you post so
infrequently yeah
yeah yeah
yeah who knows
huh i don't know i have a i have a
random question yeah um i remember
watching your channel a long time ago
um
we can't say it but you you sold these
little things oh ding yeah ding dings
and for
we won't say what they are but do you
remember how much you made from that
because i'm i was so curious i have no
idea now you got to explain with this
yeah okay so
um the pg way to explain ding dings uh
the male anatomy like sure phallic like
a little uh it's like a little little
toy but yeah squishy or something it's
really cute
yeah michael listed these for sale i and
i and i think they sold out they sold
pretty well yeah i think i remember
it was a long time ago
i remember selling like
i don't know 20 000 or something of them
which was a reasonable amount and at how
much a piece i they sold for like how
much 15
15 each but also the merch company
can scam me on those um the one i was
working with at the time so
i i don't know
a solid amount surely for those guys
that was a good one i want to sell
something from my next video
um
maybe later on i'm interested in that i
am i'm shocked because to me it seems
like such a i don't want to say easy but
a a simple path for you yeah just once a
month for a year yeah you'll get enough
money if you just invest it you will be
set after one year what the [ __ ] am i
going to do after a year whatever you
want right what is that going to be
literally whatever post youtube videos
oh wait i don't like it anymore i'm sad
but i'm just saying but it gives you the
option to do whatever you want if you
sacrifice one year now you will have the
rest of your life to do whatever you
want if it's posting more youtube videos
great if it's uh spending time on the
beach building robots great if you're
driving across the country great but you
will never have to worry about money
again and and i think in your situation
one year yeah it's gonna take well maybe
i don't know maybe
do you think that when you
i don't know
i don't know if i got to that point i
would be interested in
like i think money is an interesting
driving factor like it's
cool to try and make a business or
something like something i do want to do
eventually is like start my own business
um and i don't know if i'd have because
that is like obviously money oriented
like i would give more money oriented
about a business
um
so i don't know if i would have that
drive later on
to to do it if i were just set yeah for
for life but here's it but here's the
thing though i think a year's worth of
savings for you yeah wouldn't be enough
to be like just balling it up i'm not
talking like oh it's not like
rolls-royce money
this would be enough where it would pay
your living expenses food and just allow
a little bit of saving yeah for one year
yeah so it wouldn't so i don't think
that would that would lower your
motivation one bit i think you could be
just as motivated but i mean like even
right now like for a while like like i
could just live i just want to know that
i'm not homeless you know that's that's
yeah where i'm at got it yeah i think
that you just it's comforting for me
because you're so not money motivated at
all and you know for a fact that you'll
be happy
right with with very little yeah i'll
survive for sure you'll survive and be
fine because your average day just like
you told me in the car just consists of
like video games
hanging out with friends going for hikes
sometimes learning stuff something
learning i do a lot of like learning
stuff right um and like quite a bit is
like still working on the video and
stuff but
yeah there's like a lot of like
just you know fun bits yeah
it's just interesting comparing that
with graham right
which i mean you do what makes you happy
i do the time right
i enjoy making money yeah yeah i look
every hour i'm like how can i optimize
yeah that's a fun game it's fun to be
like
it's like in a video game where you're
like trying to max it out like it's fun
i just don't want to make something else
i want to make it a separate thing you
know i don't want it to overtake
my like enjoyment for doing stuff
um so yeah
so how do you find out what you enjoy
you just wake up one day and you're like
i feel like doing this
working on different things
learning youtube videos
learning yeah youtube videos yeah um
new technology i try to like
learn
stuff even if i don't know where it's
gonna go to um
just because like sometimes like you
gotta like a buy a tool before you use
it
um so like i obviously i didn't
think of learning facial recognition
with the thought of uh making like the
lasers
but just because you know it's like oh
you can do this and this and put these
things together because you know them
it's not like not the other way around
so i'm trying to get as many like things
that i do know got it so you can put
them together what's something that
you're learning at the moment or just
something that you've learned i'm doing
a lot of statistical analysis from this
recent video which is really fun it's
like data visualization stuff super
[ __ ] cool uh sentiment analysis i'm
working with like large data sets so
here's the thing if you create a program
like that you could sell the program all
right
and that'd be fun and i'd be super into
the money if i were doing it yes that
specifically yeah yeah um let's get to
the topic of you selling everything
why'd you do that oh i sold all my stuff
yeah because you told me uh uh it must
have been a year ago that you had
sold no you bought simon property group
yeah you were like all in simon
properties
and you did well yeah because i think
since then simon property group is up
about hundred and fifty percent that's
not 700 percent yeah and uh the
dividends on that you bought in when it
was paying probably like a nine percent
yeah yeah that was on a tip from a
friend yeah um and i remember saying i
bought some simon property group just
not as much as you yeah yeah yeah doing
great the only the reason i sold was
because i was really afraid of the
chinese uh housing market the
their their largest housing firm went
bankrupt ever right yeah every grant
yeah and that's scary because um
in china that's like their way to invest
if like you have extra money like that's
the only way you can invest in china
because you can't go into the stock
market because it's owned by like the
state i mean even your house is on by
this year you know you can't buy a house
yeah it's like you lease it from the
states you buy nine you buy the rights
for 99 years
they're the ones that own it yeah
actually you have no idea weird right
yeah so if you invest in china you're
always investing in real estate and
their main realistic company like went
under so that just scared me
um i think their market cap was like
greater than lehman brothers or
something and so just hearing that i
wanted to just like unexpose for like a
month or two but then go back when did
you sell
i don't know like
like something like a month or two ago
less a month ago a month ago
uh so it's probably up since you've sold
i'm guessing yeah but yeah yeah the
thing with that with evergrand is that
there's not that much exposure to the us
i think i think it was something like
five percent the like it's very little i
was afraid of like some horrible chain
reaction no that's what i was afraid no
yeah so
um i was out and then
because then you also have a capital
gains tax on that yeah well i was going
to get back in and then
russia went to war with ukraine
and i was like that's weird and scary
and i don't know
what that does to the stock market
because i've never lived that before you
should watch my videos yeah yeah yeah
i've gone over the studies on that yeah
yeah uh so i didn't know so i was just
i'm i would rather remove myself from
the risk of a highly volatile thing for
a few months other than making a few
percent yeah how much profit did you
have because you must i'm guessing you
probably have an svg yeah like a few
hundred thousand dollars that's a lot of
money but i
i
i don't know i think a lot okay it's a
lot a lot surely because it was like a
lucky it was from a friend um
yeah that was a good one also i think
amd was up a lot from when i bought it
right something like 30 40 percent yeah
the issue i see on that there's nothing
selling out of
you know simon property group to buy
something else but the issue is that
you're going to be hit with this capital
gains tax
yeah 35 has gone to that i was aware
yeah yeah
versus i i would have kept it because
the dividend that you're getting on that
you're getting like five percent six
percent on on your money but higher on
the amount that you've invested yeah
probably five four and a half five
percent on the money that the value of
that that's you know yeah yeah that's
really strong i just feared end of days
but okay yeah kevin o'leary says what
graham you shouldn't jealous not sell a
stock because of taxes yes
that's from kevin o'leary himself just
dictate whether it yourself yeah
that's true
listen it is true but i think when you
when you live in california
uh you have to pay an extra 10 percent
on that it's just
there are ways that you could borrow
against that if you needed more money or
you needed to have yeah
i was just worried about the market so
probably get back in probably do some
quirky [ __ ] maybe do some nvidia
the 40 series will come out soon i think
that's gonna
do excellently got it yeah
i'm kind of curious of what your living
expenses are like because last time we
talked like we mentioned it was about a
year ago yeah and you don't have
expensive taste you don't spend a lot of
money i think you did spend a lot of
money on ubereats though i i did but
i've been cooking more recently yeah
yeah so it hasn't been so bad yeah so
what what i mean
walk us through like your your average
monthly expenses what's like the most
all
[ __ ] i don't know um insurance health
insurance
um which i do have i found out when i
went to the er that i do have health
insurance which is nice oh yeah you got
you got food poisoning food poisoning or
something the reason i didn't go to the
er because i got food poisoning i went
because there was blood in the vomit so
that's what i was like i should go to
the emergency room wow cause i i like
like i thought through the stream you'd
go to yeah yeah yeah i threw everything
up and then i got to the bile and there
were like chunks of brown and i looked
it up and it was like that is congealed
blood and i was like i don't think
that's blood no and i called my dad who
was a nurse and he's like that is blood
go to the emergency send him a picture
of it yeah okay is i go to the emergency
room and so i went i know it was all
right they ct did it
what was the what was the deal they
didn't they got the doctor barely talked
to me they were busy as [ __ ] so
i i don't know they said you're fine and
i left and you were fine and i was like
what was the bill for that
like 200 bucks
that's it because i had health insurance
which is crazy not know you have health
insurance i didn't i know you you have
to have something but
well i didn't for a long time yeah and i
got it i don't know maybe like a year
ago and forgot it i guess wow kaiser
yeah do you know how much you pay on
that no i don't remember
um okay i do know that i waited four
hours in the [ __ ] er though in the er
lounge like in the er lobby waiting to
go into the er and you wouldn't
recognize it
no michael reeves just puking my guts
out yeah
it was bad
guys i got a stab wound
michael yo let me get a selfie really
quick there was this guy who got maced
and he was like pissed that that weight
was like four hours oh my gosh it's like
i got [ __ ] amazed
let me end and he's like i gotta wait in
this [ __ ] life
that's what i was wondering i was like
what did you do that made you get messed
up does that go away i thought that
didn't last like an hour dude last
forever really that lasts like like a
few hours i think getting maced is
extremely painful but i think unless
you're in life-threatening [ __ ] they
will not
bring you in like in in the fast pass
by the time that they allow you he was
he actually didn't end up going in
because he was all right by the end yeah
i feel like they would question like you
know how did you get
made you do this to yourself are you
doing something i robbed a lady yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she wouldn't give me her purse
she faced me and this is her fault yeah
you know what the crazy thing in the in
the u.s legal system let's say he's
trying to steal a purse and gets maced
and has to go to the hospital imagine
that guy's suing for damages
i bet he could i bet there's some lawyer
out there she'd have to pay for a lawyer
would take that case yeah i feel like we
can win it yeah and we'll just say
listen lady it's cheaper you just pay
him 20 grand and settle because
otherwise they could drag this out for
years and uh you're better off
that's that's how it works in the united
states i think it's just like the reason
how much damage they caused though
because
you know if if i think the the whole
thing is like if he's trying to steal
like a a thousand dollar phone right
is macing him let's say and then
for some reason your mace was like bad
and he went blind
is
is a reasonable like action to getting
your phone stolen to blind someone i
think that's kind of what they look at
yeah no they could they could sue for
whatever and most insurance companies i
didn't realize this they choose to
automatically settle it's cheaper for
them as an insurance company hey we're
going to pay 10 20 grand
rather than investigate and spend our
resources on this
seriously the lady like pulls out a
sheet yeah it's like doing them but this
is how much is in their purse
throughout businesses um uh auto
incidents the insurance are just like
sell settle settle
because it's a cost benefit thing um
even a buddy who owns like a physical
storefront he get he's he's been sued
now like four or five times yeah two
years but because of frivolous lawsuits
like a lady will walk out front
slip yeah and find an injury attorney
who will represent and it's just like
settle for 10k or we're gonna take this
to court and it's way more expensive for
you oh my god so even if you win even if
you're in the right it's on camera
you're going to win you really want to
spend uh 15 grand fighting this even
though you win or tremendously you pay
10k right now and you walk away and even
if they do win the lady who slipped and
fell what does she have let's say you
win the judgment she's got 500 to her
name where are you going to collect that
from or not
you won the lawsuit but you lost yeah so
it's pretty it's pretty bad that's fun
but that yeah but that but that reminds
me of the the whole health insurance
thing that i have basically this is like
the crappiest policy yeah it's basically
meant for like a catastrophic plan where
i'm paying out of pocket the first eight
thousand dollars i got a bad one too
yeah well no not if you're going to the
er for something let's cover it special
i don't remember getting like a good one
it's i don't know yeah it was my last
time at the the doctor and this is why
like i hate to say like i've stopped
going but it was like three or four
years ago i went to get uh what was it i
think i just had low energy or something
like that and yeah but it was like a
persistent low energy and i went in
thinking like maybe my levels are off or
something like that so i did a full
range of blood tests yeah check your ph
with the test strips yeah take the ph
take the salinity and like all that sort
of the temperature
did the full range of blood tests
and uh came back and thankfully
everything was fine and they you know
maybe it was a stress or something but
anyway i remember getting this bill in
the mail for like seven thousand dollars
for like blood tests
and i'm like this should have been
covered under preventative yeah and they
say
nope the way it's coated is that this
was like something extra and it's not
covered and i remember spending weeks on
the phone back and forth with both the
hospital another hospital the doctor's
office and the insurance company trying
to get this thing resolved yeah it took
a long time and eventually got resolved
and eventually had to pay the fifty
dollars but i was like that's a long
time but it wasn't worth it like if you
add in my time and then the other one is
i convinced myself i had melanoma
because i looked at a mole and i was
like yeah that's melanoma
and um
i i called for my uh for for the for the
doctor to like get in
because it should be covered under
preventative and so in order to do that
you need to go and set up an appointment
with a normal doctor to then be referred
out to a skin doctor and this could take
uh you know it will we'll book you in
like a few weeks and then it'll be
another few weeks i'm like that's two
months if i had melanoma
uh so that whole process guess how much
it cost me out of pocket just to just to
make an appointment pay out of pocket
for this thing like 450 250 and i made
an appointment for the next day that's
250 versus this other one where i have
to make an appointment go to this thing
wait a few weeks get referred it's not
worth it it's so bad it's like i'd
rather just pay for it at that point
yeah why do you have healthcare in the
first place i don't know
yeah i mean
yes um yeah it's bad like part of me
would rather just like save the money
and pay out of pocket but you know i'm
paying i think it's 300 a month for
basically if
something happens i'm covered above
eight thousand dollars so i look at it
like some like horrible [ __ ] yeah so i'd
rather just be covered yeah that's cool
that's good yeah yeah like if you hit me
in the boxing ring
and you died
let's not
let's maybe not okay let's put that
yeah that out um no no no oh yeah we're
boxing yeah no i think we include it in
the thing it'll be interesting no i mean
i mean clip it so that after you die we
have a couple yeah oh gosh i don't even
prove it i listen i am i'm so serious
i'm so superstitious about this right on
the epoxy yeah i always worry that
graham will be there man you will
something into existence by joking about
it and then it happens
no it's okay like you joke about that
and then it happens you know
he's a very superstitious person that's
interesting
he's incredibly superstitious we post
that like for example he always wants to
sit on the couch in a certain spot
because videos will do better if we like
post there dude i get that about youtube
stuff like yeah yeah
knocking on what yeah posting at a
certain time that one thing but
it's it's always stuff like this where
they look back at podcaster like that
was the moment he said it he said he
willed it yes exactly and i believe in
that stuff so now it's like have we just
i don't know anyway so we should talk
about the beef right because you guys
have some serious beef yeah you're gonna
be settling with your fists and your
faces yeah you're pissed so what's going
on with that why why each other they're
boxing for those that yeah michael and
graham yeah
why'd you why did you agree to it
so how did you agree to do it
[Laughter]
yeah so ian idubbbz uh asked if i would
want to do a charity boxing match and my
first question was how much do i make
from it and no it doesn't work like that
no no charity it's a charity but i'm
like oh man so like
i may as well and he's like well but if
you get a sponsor you could keep the
sponsor mine like oh okay fine but i i
said yes because i felt like it was
something that
10 years from now i would look back and
regret not having done it i think i did
it for a similar reason really yeah i
did it in my initial reaction i was at
like a shoot thing
with william osman items was sir and he
was like
i don't want to do this boxing match and
my initial thing was like no no i don't
want to do a boxing match i don't get
hit yeah and then i was like
i like shot back to like me in middle
school watching
ian idubbbz on youtube i was like what
the [ __ ] what do you think and then
immediately i just blurted out yes of
course yeah and that was it that was
this sealed the [ __ ] deal yeah
like okay i ian asked you to do a boxing
match like that's the weirdest cool
thing ever i it took me like a week to
say yes to it yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i and
logically my answer should have been no
time commitment and i added up in my
mind i'm like if i spend an hour you
know doing this three times a week if i
could spend an hour doing something else
over this you know i
it didn't make any sense to me and i
almost said no but then i thought well
it's it's a unique experience it'll be a
good push to get like in shape similar
yeah an excuse to go like the gym more
yeah or again at all yeah and i'd never
had a trainer before like i would go
with friends who like you know would go
to the gym but that's about it
but it's it's yeah it's way different
than i thought and i went into it
thinking like i'll have an edge because
i lift weights and go to the gym and
then i remember the first time i did
this like my my hands were all like all
messed up and like yeah i couldn't use
like my phone yeah
i felt so sore and i was like oh crap
and then and then there was that wave of
like did i make a mistake did i just
sign up for something i don't know yeah
um and then i thought well you know what
technically i don't have to say i don't
have to commit a hundred percent of this
until later so i get more of these and
but yeah i i just feel bad about uh you
know canceling yeah
well
yeah i just feel bad about that i'll be
doing it
i'll do it i sound like you don't really
want to do it i'll do it i feel bad
about you
you know why it's just i don't want it i
don't want to get hurt i have some
apprehensions i definitely had
references so going in i think i thought
to myself well if there's any damage
that's not repairable like my mind to me
is so important
that if if anything
even hinders that by a percent it's not
working it would suck yeah yeah um
same thing like let's just say i get hit
in the face and i get like a black eye
or something like that i i have to film
so it's like yeah i don't want to be
covering that up i don't want to be in a
position where i'm like i'm swelling
that'd be cool to have for a film
just for a bit i don't know i guess it's
just getting hurt if i knew i would do
it and not get hurt or not have an
injury i couldn't recover from within a
day
yeah i think he's trying to make you
feel bad
yeah i don't want to die either yeah
you've been training pretty rigorously
though uh not like rigorously but
i it's supposed to be like three or four
times a week but recently i like my neck
going to this
um
then i had the like food poisoning or
like stomach virus or whatever that was
and then i'm going to a conference in
like this week so it's like huge lull
and
working out which sucks um
but yeah i i've been trying to trying to
eat better and like trying to just do it
yeah when you find out you were first
fighting graham yeah what was your
initial reaction we were like i could
beat him it was like thank god i'm not
fighting i was gonna fight uh captain
sparkles oh no who's [ __ ] like ripped
i looked like yeah
and also has been boxing for like a year
and ian was like yeah that would be a
fun fun match and i was like please i
was like i i said i would do it just
know i will get knocked out for sure and
then i talked to
um captain sparkles and i think he's the
one who was like i don't think we should
do this that looks bad on his yeah that
looks bad for him for sure because he
would just [ __ ] on but not only that
he's uh he's a few inches taller than me
he's about two years taller than me he
goes to the gym right i've seen him at
the gym he is
huge yeah he's big he has the physique
that i would have if i like have a
model physique it would be his and he
already has and more than that he's been
boxing for like a year yeah and a lot of
it's probably just the technique and so
like he he has checked like i probably
would have considered a lot more if he
had no idea how to do boxing that would
have been maybe interesting i wouldn't
have done it but like the every single
thing was like my only thing was like
dude tom sparkles is pretty cool i used
to watch his youtube i used to watch his
minecraft parodies
um
so it'd be cool to get knocked out by
him but it was like that would not be a
fun match i think for
him either cause it's not a fun thing to
do on someone immediately
i i it would have been a note you know
what's interesting and i've never told
you this and maybe i told ian this i'm
not sure yeah uh somebody asked me is
either macy or jack asked me a while ago
would you ever do a boxing match and i
said
no but the only person i would say yes
to is michael reeves i swear i swear and
that's part of what fed into this that's
because that's right because uh and it's
wielding into existence
uh because when we met and we measured
our heights
it was like identical yes and even when
ian was asking like how much do you
weigh i said like yeah about 125 130.
yeah so it's the same thing so i felt
like
on an even playing field having never
boxed before in my life it would be
it would be a good match yeah so when he
said it was you i'm like
i i said i would and now it's like now
i'm being tested on this yeah to see if
i'll actually commit to it so i said yes
yeah yeah it'll be it's a good match
we're pretty like similar everything
actually yeah same height same build
yeah but i i've told everyone that you
are the wild card
because
you have this ability i think to just
like
you're so smart that you would find a
way like a technical way of like if i do
this
and i
do that with this hand then i'll win
it's like i don't know you would find i
won't be doing that i will not be smart
well i guess you probably shouldn't say
your strategy right here because i don't
even have this yeah
my strategy right now is not getting hit
yeah
this is so hard for me to visualize
imagine if either of us
both of
so us [ __ ] you're gonna have to fight at
some point
so how do you like boxing so far
it's
it's not what i expected yeah surely um
uh it's fun when you're doing it right
it's not fun when i get when i [ __ ] i do
hear like every time i'm doing something
wrong to like jab me in the stomach with
a stick yeah and it's like i i know i do
need
that is important because it makes you
learn it yeah um
it's fun so far like it's it's a good
excuse to like exercise and
it's it's interesting yeah it's fun to
hit a pad fun to hit a bag
i haven't hit a bag yet yeah no you're
doing pads mostly pants
yeah but yeah i was telling my guy has
these big fluffy not fluffy but like the
poofy uh mitts or the gloves yeah and
yeah if i put my hand down he'll poop
if you put him down i'm like oh man but
sometimes i'm telling like it hurts it
hurts just use it no keep going gotta
learn it and yeah and sometimes they'll
put them up to here and it'll go boop
just in the stomach yeah and then it's
like so he's like you gotta kind of
crunch over like this
yeah and then sometimes he'll just go
wailing on me
he's enjoying it way too much but but i
moved back he's like don't move back
don't move back you just it's better for
you to sustain your ground or move to
the side because once you look back then
it's like you're off balance when you're
off balance and you lose eye contact
uh
so many things that uh dude yeah a lot
of weird things you don't expect for
sure like defensive stuff i don't know
like i've watched like boxers like in
youtube videos yes and i don't know how
the they can like see where the punch is
going to come from and like
choose a defensive option like how do
you know like to pull back or go side to
side like it's such a fast thing for a
punch to come out like it's i don't know
maybe you just got to do it more yeah
i'm not that fast i'll tell you i'm
definitely not fast enough to still see
it yeah
if this brings you guys any sort of
solace i do think realistically you're
not training for too long you know great
graham does work out he's pretty strong
you said you're kind of newish to
working out i used to work out a lot
okay sure
yeah but my cardio sucks that's the
thing i do think it would be difficult
for one of you one of one of you guys
i'm saying this nicest way possible to
punch the other person so hard that
actually
hurts
but that's the thing you don't know it's
like the right hit to the right spot at
the right time like some random [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah i understand my mix
and michael comes in it just sees the
you know gets it on the side and just i
don't know it's just death yeah i
understand the worry yeah yeah i
wouldn't want that either yeah that
would suck
but you could have brain aneurysm any
time and that doesn't even involve
boxing so
yeah that's a good point my biggest
thing is hitting uh even even though the
boxing and structure instructor when
he's up he's like okay now you got one
minute you gotta hit me yeah and i
cannot it's like it's so difficult for
me really good defensively no not
defensively but like i feel bad
like even if i did hit him i would feel
so like i don't want to hurt him yeah
yeah i don't know if i could
accidentally punch my coach in the dick
really punched him right in the [ __ ]
really hard was he okay no he was he was
hurt
uh first yeah he took it like a champ
but like
i felt so [ __ ] bad i felt so
incredibly bad for hitting the deck yeah
what does your girlfriend think about
this she oh that's the best part she has
no idea why how the best part is she
doesn't know and for two months since i
found out i was doing it i've been like
throwing boxing memes at her i've been
like jabbing her in the arm and being
like hey i'm going to be a boxer and
she's like shut the [ __ ] up because i do
it
all the time
is this on purpose yes it's funny it's
starting i'll be like he i'm going to be
a boxer and and
she'll be like where are we gonna be
like doing some boxing training you know
how it is and she's like what are you
saying stop with this it's not a funny
joke to her because she thinks it's a
she joke
but if you go to training you tell her
i'm going to boxing training and she
doesn't know what you're wearing
knuckles after you come back aren't they
well we don't even we don't live in the
same place so that makes it easier um
and
so yeah and sometimes i'll just be yeah
i was at boxing usually i will not say
that but sometimes i'll be like yeah
boxing yeah and i got it even she even
saw the punching bag i have like in the
garage which i yeah and she's like she's
like you're really taking this meme far
she thinks it's for the joke
which is because i i'm like but she
doesn't even finally hit it much if you
think that like you're cheating on her
or something like be like yeah i know
we're boxing tonight
[Laughter]
sorry sorry babe like you know most of
you like my instagram
i'm like i'm not even i'm not telling
her i'm doing it usually and so i'm
building up this meme and i want to be
there when she sees ian release the card
and announce the fights and i want to be
there i didn't have videos of me like
jabbing her in the arm and being like
see i'm worried because i've mentioned
casually the fight
uh on the podcast
dude she will not she will not hear it
she probably but you don't think someone
would like watch the podcast and just
like i guess
well also he's gonna the card's gonna be
friday the announcement oh that's gonna
make it like one week yeah so it's
i've been
building this for months
is she gonna laugh i don't know it'll be
fun though that's hilarious
what do you think her reaction is she
gonna be like i think she's gonna be
like mad for like two minutes and then
really laugh a lot yeah i think she'll
be supportive about it yeah yeah
it's like a trip free trip to florida
probably go to disney world you guys go
to disney world when you go i don't know
oh that's a good idea graham wouldn't go
you're in disney world no i could work
graham's just going to get into a fight
and going out that's that's perfect for
him michael i want to know since our
last uh episode that we did yeah what
has changed for you i know we were
talking about your credit score yeah do
you get credit cards
no you didn't so nothing changed no
nothing changed nothing changed no all
right so invest more
all right invest um
yeah yeah not much change on the credit
side okay yeah
yeah no i have my own llc now which is
good for which is excellent i am told
for tax burden if you're taxed as an
escort yes yeah which is yeah so that's
good yeah right yeah i i do um
all my business and personal expenses
used to be on the same thing so that was
really hard to figure out so now it's on
like two separate
things which is that's good i guess yeah
i
do hate that stuff do you have someone
that takes care of it all for you uh
taxes yeah i do have a tax person yeah i
d man there's still so much i have to
put together though like yeah to send to
him i feel like i should just get turbo
i did mine it was oh man
i spent the entire day going through
everything that's probably the reason i
have is because there's so many
different weird places yeah and you got
like podcasts and you got youtube and
yeah and twitch had patreon yeah so much
that's a lot
yeah and the issue though is that the
irs is so backed up that even trying to
get on a phone call with them for
anything is just you cannot do it i
think uh i think i heard that only three
percent of calls to the irs right now
are being answered i didn't even know
you could call the item oh yeah
for what just say anything if you have
questions um
you could you could call them to say
what's up yeah yeah i'm about three
percent but just yeah but just getting
in you're like lucky enough to be able
to speak to someone there if anyone
works at the irs
disabled no
i'm like half joking but this is
sponsored by the
internal revenue service but no but but
no because i sent in a forum and uh i
it's just like i don't know how long
it's gonna take for like a person to
actually see this form and i'm like well
if one of our viewers wants to uh help
me out
i don't know if that's the legal thing
legally solicit the hell from just there
that's just it look it's just
incriminating
i just i just want to know if it's filed
that's fine
no no it's it's i've talked to the uh
talk to the tax person who said that
like some of these documents they've
submitted to the irs still haven't been
processed after like six to six months
to a year that's crazy so it's like some
of these things you want to be a little
bit more timely on it you don't you
don't want to just post it you know date
it and then have like a certified mail
you want to know
so if anyone's there who wants to check
my
mail for me that'd be good i just wanna
you know just or not or i'm joking but
if it's illegal he's joking if i'm yeah
i don't know if that's legal to ask if
someone at the irons could just take a
look and make sure they received it
you know jokingly of course
i don't know i
just don't want to make sure they
receive it that's all they're going to
want to make sure they get get the forms
on time and get the [ __ ]
anxious like that that's all yeah so uh
so nothing has changed since then your
credit was no no
not financial much wise yeah did you was
there any take away from our from our
video that you're like i learned
something or no i sh i should get a
credit card yeah
but i still have not okay if you got a
pa they would do it for you probably
yeah yeah you have an assistant right
now or no yeah how much are you working
would you say on an average day
depends on like
the the era
like some sometimes it's like many days
of doing nothing and then some days it's
like many days is the only thing i do is
work it's like yeah i don't know or like
right now working on this video it's
like get up just work on the thing and
then go to sleep mostly so yeah how many
hours did you see you have in this video
i have in this video oh my god
um
hundreds
hundreds are you serious yeah easily
because behind the scenes like
like even in that shitty presentation
yeah i was i was like i have to go into
like my graphing software i have to go
into like not the software i have to
like make the software and i have to
like use and i'm like okay i have to
build out these graphs i have to model
the you know crunch the data set like to
look like this so it fits into these
graphs i have to look up like okay how
did like the dow do i'm gonna now get
that data i'm gonna plot that data
against my graphs it's like so much on
the back end that it's like if i get a
new idea for something it's like okay
that's gonna be five hours six hours for
like a little thing like even those
shitty graphs but isn't something like
that couldn't you have someone else
graph that for you maybe but they'd have
to be extremely involved like have
access to my all my files and stuff
they'd have to be really specialized too
because most people don't do like
most people are like really good at this
and they would be able to blow through
this but then i'd have to like get
another person to do something else if
i'm working on something else so they
would be able to do this better
but it would they would only be able to
do this probably um
yeah so i also like to know what's going
on i really do like to
have an idea of the full picture yeah so
and working on every little bit helps me
get an idea of the full picture yeah
surely hundreds though
um
yeah
the graphing wasn't i feel like you
could have done uh for the for the
amount of time you could have spent 12
hours making the fart car horns
and just doing that and finding a way to
hack that so that people when they honk
through horn you're caught off guard and
just a compilation of that that's a fun
one yeah it's also hard to come up with
ideas sometimes
for a good idea what are some of the
other ideas that you've had that you
abandoned oh baby killing drone
that's it baby killing drone now why did
you abandon that idea
why was that a bad idea told me it was
insensitive
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was gonna be a
drone with a big spike on it
and it could detect babies and kill them
i'm dying
what if it accidentally saw a real life
baby yeah babies would have definitely
been too shitty to kill a baby like a
real baby but i think it could have in
like a garage like a lab environment it
could have found it and and skewered a
fake baby yeah so who told you that was
a bad idea because it was like william
osman yeah okay william osman and my
manager
we're like that's a bad one do you
usually ask them for your ideas before
you do them just did like no that one
was just i think we were just talking
yeah and i was like that could be fun
that's probably like the one where i was
like hey i won't i probably won't maybe
someday i'll still [ __ ] do it yeah
that would be fun yeah
any other ideas yeah we want to hear
more of these ideas not ones that i shot
down um
there's got to be some like in the works
that you've thought of something not not
ones that i've like killed because
usually if it's if it's if i like it
i'll just do it um
there's a lot of like shitty ones though
lots of like i could just attach a taser
to something you know what would have
been nice um
is to take that you know you know the
package thief videos oh yeah the
microphone oh and just it kills them if
but if you did something that was like
even crazy yeah like it's a gun these
are super tame and it's like
but i don't know but if you could do
something like that that's like freaky
like yeah scary pepper sprays them and
taste
it as soon as they pick it up non-lethal
yeah
yeah
less than lethal yeah oh my god yeah
because the wait was four hours yeah
[ __ ] that was a long wait you could do a
video like that i feel like would do it
yeah it would be funny if if people try
to steal the package and then like as
they were trying to run off your
property you had like
four six foot eight bodyguards just step
and just close off it's gotta be no it's
gotta be the robot like maybe that's
where the drone comes in yeah the drone
just chases them off that's kind of
funny yeah they don't have some sort of
robot or some sort of wall that comes up
that boxes them in yeah that would be
that would be great that's i mean that's
imprisonment
but on your property it's it's illegal
certainly
but a door can't walk behind it's like
if they take that
the door locks they can't get out but
they're in there who's to say yeah but
there's a difference between having like
a reasonable thought that oh if you step
behind the store it might close versus
haha gotcha
businesses
around you
like like banks and stuff like that it
they they control who goes in and out if
there's something someone steals
something they lock them in sorry i
guess they do do that yeah i wonder if
there's a lot of gallons in that one
yeah
yeah i i haven't even asked my like um
tax
person about how this video is gonna
work
for the fish
i don't know what do you think even that
happens for what the investment
well you can't you can't write off the
investment
so yeah so that's not yeah you're not
writing off the investment now here's
the thing it's not even me really buying
the stocks so really should i be paying
that tax yeah because it's a fish thing
but where's the money going once you
pull out who says i'm gonna pull out
yeah i mean let's say you keep it in
there but the thing is then everyone
would call their investments a business
because then i would be like well i
invested a hundred thousand dollars with
the monkey as a business expense and
then right off that investment that's
maybe like you can do that that's maybe
like the closest [ __ ] thing you could
do you wouldn't be able to i mean if you
did yeah if you get audited then it's
like well hey you i mean that's pretty
obvious like anything can audit me
me
irs
i mean they're trying
listen you never know but my point being
like technically you're not supposed to
write that off if you paid someone for
software or whatever then you'd write
that off as an expense but yeah but yeah
it's something like that you would not
be able to yeah i i doubt i will
i can't wait to explain to them though
you could try yeah how about this i
would try and just say like i think can
i do this and see what their reaction is
that'll be a fun conversation to have
yeah with them but yeah
because yeah that's your investment so
plus you didn't lose any money now if
you lost money you'd be right off i lost
money for sure because the other bot
lost money oh you did you did okay well
you can just whatever the loss is you're
going to use that loft to offset your
gain yeah so at the end of this tax year
what i would do is sell the losing
portfolio irs sell the equivalent amount
of the the winning portfolio to then
reset your tax basis
so that way i'll save a little bit on
taxes
yeah i'll do that
yeah um what questions you have for us
unless jack needs it i have one more
question jack has a question so a lot of
people consider you like a youtuber's
youtuber because your type of like video
production skills and stuff like that is
like uh it's really admired by a lot of
youtubers like people look up to you i
ask a lot of youtubers like who they
watch and a lot of them say michael
reeves oh that's sweet and i want to
know what are some of the stuff that you
pay attention to in your own videos
because it seems like like every single
second of your videos is like perfect
like there's perfect build up there's
like good climax there's resolution like
all this stuff scripting extremely good
scripting like even the production
quality it's like i notice how your your
camera quality and your audio quality
it's not perfect but it's kind of mr
beast desk because he's gone on record
and said he tries to make it
like he doesn't have super high-res
video quality or like audio quality
perfect do you look into that type of
stuff or what strategies do you look
like do no i like your videos like you
do i don't uh i know i don't even uh
script the videos there's no script for
anything wow that's impressive i uh the
way i i
make it is i think i said it last time
where i'll just shoot like
i'll shoot like 30 seconds worth of
footage like in video time and then go
to the editing and then edit it and then
i'll shoot the next 30 seconds and then
just do this [ __ ] hellish back do you
do like
you know first try second take third
take four yeah i'll i'll usually like i
can
see like what i need to do based on like
what i've done before it so it's like
i'll do like you know if i'm like two
minutes i'm like okay i don't know what
needs to happen here and i'll like edit
it together and i'm like that needs to
get filmed so i'll go film that come
back it's like this slow lego building
block hell that i've made for myself
um
yeah so that helps me keep track of
what's happening like have an idea of
what's uh i think if i tried to do it
all in footage and then edit it one i
would want to kill myself because the
editing in chunks i hate like a huge big
glob of editing to do um
and i would have like way less of an
idea of how like everything fits
together and like i should have done
that way faster or i should have done
this part with more explanation
if if you're like editing it and i'm i
watch it a bunch of times like up to the
point that i'm trying to
like to the end point that i've got i'm
like okay this part obviously needs to
be a little faster because it's boring
up until her
you know yeah okay yeah so you get a
better idea for like how to film a
better idea for how to edit i don't know
oh yeah it's slow by the time you reach
the end you've seen that you've seen it
so many hundred times
yeah yeah i'm tired of watching this
video right um do you have it can i see
it i don't have it oh
man it's like okay most of the way done
like 90 done this uh your part was
actually like a big part of it oh cool
yeah i needed that that was a chunk and
i it's hard to work on the [ __ ] it was
actually a huge blog because i was like
i want to see what it looks like edited
with your bit before i do any others
wow so it's like i don't yeah that's an
honor yeah wow that's a lot of pressure
what if you don't like well yeah i i i
said if you cut it out i'm not going to
be no it was good like whatever it was
good yeah yeah it's just the the level
of commitment because otherwise if we
didn't do this you would literally be
flying in here for really 20 minutes
like 15 minutes of filming yeah to leave
i mean it makes more sense than driving
to boston that was a long time but just
the commitment it would be way easier
well it wouldn't be the same of uh like
just having me film my part and yeah
yeah because now i can have like a
picture of me flying to vegas like a
little map yeah and i get to do like two
seconds of out the window yeah people
appreciate that stuff that's fun they
notice and i think it's funny to like go
here just to get that yeah bit yeah yeah
like it's funny to drive across the u.s
to get that yeah i would have loved you
for you to have pitched this like kevin
o'leary or like yeah cuban or like some
someone like that yeah i don't know how
to get in contact with those guys though
they are uh
i can help with kevin o'leary oh yeah
yeah
if i can do it within a week then i do
that
that'd be cool it is but yeah i can ask
yeah that would be sick if you could ask
that would be something yeah that'd be
awesome okay i'd put that in for sure
yeah
yeah that'd be lit besides that what
else has changed we got we got alex
since the last time that uh yeah yeah
how was your video so dedicated editor
right
honestly kind of a little bit of
everything but mainly editing yeah yeah
so alex edits probably four out of five
videos on the main channel okay uh some
of the like the the last minute videos i
edit those myself
and then alex is uh
yeah he helps share in the podcast too
and uh random stuff like we're trying to
get a pergola made in the back and i'm
like alex
go to town
give me a pergola yeah and then the the
other thing like a gazebo typing
on
and then uh alex helped me frame the
goosebumps books so i bought like the
entire series of goosebumps in mint
condition and i wanted them framed to
put on the wall
and god the frames were three times more
expensive than the bookstore wow yeah
build your own that's awesome yeah that
was sweet yeah so yeah it was eighteen
hundred dollars for the three frames
for three yes it was six did you get a
customer yes they had to be because they
have to fit the width of the book wow
and so so the books don't get damaged
it's basically like this piece of foam
that they cut out in the exact shape of
the book
and then they put the book in there and
seal it together i got that's a lot of
money yeah but that's great but i
consider it like art i like the
goosebumps books yeah that's like that's
a cool one that's like the pokemon card
poster you got yeah that's sick
so i thought it's like art and for like
an art piece of collectible books i
thought it was pretty cool yeah that's
quite sweet yeah yeah would you ever uh
outsource your editing michael
uh it's hard because i do that weird
thing where i go like back and forth so
it's i don't think i could like it's
maybe for like a huge chunk where it's
really annoying and i just need to do
the rough rough cut stuff um
i have a hard time like trusting others
though
not just in youtube in my life
um
but
yeah i think it would be hard with the
way i film
so i it's not something i am looking for
right now like it's
if anything it would be like someone to
help me with
like engineering stuff that i am bad at
like mechanical and electrical probably
my weakest bits of engineering so
maybe maybe like a really good
uh
what is that
me engineer
mechanical electrical engineer yeah
yeah that'd be cool
yeah i don't know i see you i think if
you got an assistant yeah it's like a
part-time assistant for random stuff i
think that's what you need no one
full-time yeah no editor but just a good
but just a smart person to help you on
the side with like researching stuff or
like helping you pull some of these
things together yeah graphs and just
stuff like this that you could work with
somebody on to speed up the process yeah
that might be cool someone local who who
will work like any hours like you're
like hey come over at 1 am yeah we're
going to be working on this be like yeah
i've been thinking about it i've been
playing with that idea yeah it would be
like really helpful for something that's
like pages
like putting together my garage after i
move it's still not together it's taking
so much time see something like that
just a jack of all trades and pay them
69 420 a year yeah
that'd be sweet and that's and that's
what they make but it's just odd hours
just be ready any time
just be on call 24 7.
don't call call me i'll just call you
when i when you get that call on this
cell phone then you drop everything and
you come work oh man none of those yeah
that'd be cool to have what would you
say motivates you um
i don't know memes
memes memes like what is something that
you that you aspire to to do in this
somewhat near future something you want
um
memes memes yeah
do
epic trolling uh
no uh i don't know i have no like near
future goal finish this [ __ ] video
for the love of god and then do another
one really fast afterwards so that i
don't wait another year that
wait why do you wait a year because i
guarantee in a year it must have been
some idea that well this one was just
painful this one not painful but like
took a lot of time grueling there was a
lot of like time-based aspects that i
could not change by like working more
efficiently like it has to trade stocks
for a month or two um
yeah just getting everything together
learning how to use like stock market
api figuring out like the workflow of it
um it was a lot yeah so ideally i start
faster again maybe work more efficiently
because there's a bunch of [ __ ] that i
want to do
but i'm slow and shitty yeah so my
favorite video from yours was was the
roomba video
yeah that was my favorite one i think if
you did another one of those i think i
think something involving a tesla
yeah something the fart noise the horn
like something like that i made my tesla
a roomba
cleans up salt flats just something like
that or or you know the tesla peas or
the tesla's
if it's beer if someone gets too close
to the car like something happens
someone kills them you know what yeah
i'm gonna make a boxing glove with a gun
in it
like yeah maybe maybe yeah
maybe not
but like in l.a there's all these car
thefts right now like people are
complaining like cars are getting broken
into maybe you set up your tesla's like
a bait car and like if they break and
steal something the tesla i don't know
that would be crazy yeah i bet you that
would be dangerous and illegal though if
you said the car is a bait car and then
as soon as it like it started taking off
you blared music like super loud or some
meme songs
[Applause]
i think my like the maximum you can go
with that if you've ever seen the video
of the guy who did that with bikes yeah
and yeah tied the rope to it and it'll
like yeah and there's one where there
was a taser attached it might have been
fake yeah but that's like an awesome
idea that i wish i could
do that or maybe like no because then
you're hurting people yeah that's the
thing like a piston to throw them off
the bike hilariously launch them into
like a pool yeah yeah that would be
funny but then you're like that's like
lost
hurt anybody
yeah yeah the most he could probably do
is like i don't know if you guys saw um
i think was it
was it dustin from smart everyday where
he made like a
a bicycle but the handlebars were
reversed oh yeah i did see that it's
like the pedaling was backwards right no
it was like the actual handlebar yeah
you turn it right and it goes left yeah
oh
right yeah that would be funny to watch
people steal like yeah and then they get
on and they try to yeah that is a good
idea yeah i should do that
that's smart
all right well i'm good yeah yeah
cool thank you for having me thank you
for getting your free stock down below
public.com
we're gonna have a lot of editing to do
on this see i don't know if we like
technically we should bleep out some of
the swearing i some of it but i feel
like it doesn't matter that much
technically there's not supposed to be
any swearing in the first 30 seconds
yeah
i hate that role
that was awesome man you guys didn't
even end the podcast thanks for watching
guys thank you thank you thanks michael
don't forget thank you guys oh and
subscribe and subscribe all right come
on